les murs étaient entièrement recouvert
de moquette d'une moquette orange mais
sale et le plafond était pas en marron
presque noir sombre trop petit les
locaux du secours populaire de
versailles avait besoin d'un coup de
neuf
après six mois de travaux les bénévoles
viennent de finir d'installer le
vestiaire un lieu aux allures de petite
boutique qui correspond mieux aux
demandes des bénéficiaires c'est très
difficile pour cette personne est
arrivée dans un lieu qui est austère
antipathique presque insalubre
c'est pas digne ce n'est pas respecté
l'ordre donc vraiment nous notre souci
c'était d'abord l'accueil un accueil
plus moderne mais aussi plus chaleureux
avant les bénéficiaires attendait sur
des chaises dans ce couloir avec l'aide
de la mairie le secours populaire s'est
doté d'un nouveau pôle alimentaire qu'il
a voulu colorée inspirée des salons de
thé en comptant les deux locaux 113
mètres carrés ont été entièrement
refaits par une quinzaine de bénévoles
de l'antenne toutes les peintures les
enduits la reflète la réfection du sol
on a des projets maintenant qu'on est
qu'on peut accueillir des familles et on
va on a des projets de goûter lecture là
parmi nos bénévoles une institutrice qui
se propose de faire un jour un atelier
conte l'inauguration officielle de ses
nouveaux locaux se tiendra vendredi 7
octobre
cinq mille euros ont été nécessaires
pour réaliser ces travaux financés par
les dons
la structure s'occupe de 250 familles
inscrites l'an dernier elle a distribué
trois mille neuf cents repas